a massive suspected russian cyber hack
hits a load of american agencies
democrats insist on retribution while
pushing for wins in georgia and stimulus
talks continue to drag out i'm ben
shapiro this is the ben shapiro show
today's show is sponsored by expressvpn
thousands of my listeners have already
secured their internet join them at
expressvpn.com
ben we'll get to all the news in just
one moment first let me remind you
you're spending too much money on your
cell phone bill yeah are
because you went to one of those big
providers didn't you and they just told
you that you needed
all of the things you needed unlimited
talk and unlimited text and unlimited
data well here's the thing you're not
using unlimited data because nobody uses
unlimited data
what you actually need is unlimited talk
unlimited text and two gigs of data for
just 20 bucks a month
well what happens if you go over on data
usage well pure talk usa won't charge
you for it so that means you're getting
the best deal possible from pure talk at
usa you're also
getting the exact same coverage same
bars as one of the big carriers but
they're going to be charging you half of
what you would normally be
charged by one of these big mobile
carriers so how do you switch
easy grab your mobile phone dial pound
250 say ben shapiro that's it
when you do you'll save 50 off your
first month style pound
2 5 0 say keyword ben shapiro you don't
have to sacrifice customer service
either their team is based right here in
the united states
some of the nicest people you'll ever
talk to dial pound two five zero say
keyword
ben shapiro to get started with pure
talk usa don't spend too much money with
one of the big cell phone carriers
instead
make sure that you are spending your
money where it counts at puretalk usa
puretalk is simply
smarter wireless now pound two five zero
say keyword bench appear or get fifty
percent off your first month along with
all the other savings
we have been talking about all right so
in one of the least noticed
stories that is actually an enormous
story in recent memory
there's an enormous russian mega hack
apparently suspected russian mega hack
against a bevy of top american agencies
and top
american companies according to the
associated press u.s government agencies
and private companies rushed monday
to secure their computer networks
following the disclosure of a
sophisticated and long-running cyber
espionage intrusion
suspected of being carried out by
russian hackers the full extent of the
damage is not yet clear
the potential threat was significant
enough that the department of homeland
security's cyber security unit directed
all federal agencies
to remove compromised network management
software and thousands of companies were
expected to do the same by the way there
are certain sources saying it's not
going to be sufficient to remove the
software you're actually going to have
to unplug the actual hardware get rid of
it and replace it which isn't which is
crazy
that's how infected these systems have
become
according to the ap what was striking
about the operation was its potential
scope
as well as the manner in which the
perpetrators managed to pierce cyber
defenses and gain access to email
and internal files at the treasury and
commerce department and potentially
elsewhere
the intrusion was stark evidence of the
vulnerability of even supposedly secure
government networks even
after well-known previous attacks it's
still not clear who exactly did this
although u.s officials are suggesting it
is probably russian hackers
the washington post citing unnamed
sources says the attack was carried out
by russian government hackers who go by
the nicknames apt-29 or cozy bear
which sounds cuter than it is and are
part of that nation's foreign
intelligence service
the intrusion came to light after a
prominent cyber security from fireeye
determined it had been breached and
alerted
that government for alerted that foreign
governments and major corporations were
also
compromised so how significant is this
breach it's significant enough
that for example the bush cybersar
richard clark said this is the largest
espionage attack in history
in american history this is the largest
espionage attack
in history this is as though the
russians got a pass key
a skeleton key for about half the locks
in the country
think about it that way yeah it's 18 000
companies and government institutions
scattered around the us and the world
this is an espionage attack as far as we
know the reason they got in was to steal
information from the us government
president trump's own ex-homeland
security adviser agreed he said the
magnitude of this thing
is difficult to overstate he said it's
the russians have had access to a
considerable number of important and
sensitive networks for six to nine
months the russian svr will surely have
used its access to further exploit and
gain administrative control
over the networks that considered
priority targets for those targets the
hackers will have long ago moved past
their entry point
covered their tracks and gained what
experts call persistent access meaning
the ability to infiltrate and control
networks in a way that is hard to detect
or remove while the russians didn't have
time to gain complete control over every
network they hacked they most certainly
did gain it over hundreds of them
it'll take years to know for certain
which networks the russians control
and which ones they just occupy so how
did they gain access
according to the cyber security and
infrastructure security agency known as
saiza they said in an unusual directive
the widely used network software solar
winds
have been compromised and should be
removed from any system using it the
problem is that once the system has used
it
the russians are already inside the
system in all probability
national cyber security agencies of
britain and ireland also issued similar
alerts so this isn't a purely american
problem
solarwinds is used by hundreds of
thousands of organizations around the
world including most fortune 500
companies
multiple u.s federal agencies the
perpetrators were able to embed malware
in a security update issued by the
company
based in austin texas so basically it
wasn't that
you know somebody clicked on a phishing
link or something it wasn't like when
john podesta got hacked by the wikileaks
guys
simply by clicking on a phishing link
instead what happened here is that
solarwinds which again is a major
company
issued a sort of software update and
people just hit
sure update my software and with that
software came the malware
those solar runs estimated 18 000
customers were infected most of the
malware was not activated
when it was hackers could impersonate
system administrators and have total
access
to the infected networks carmichael said
that the highly disciplined hackers only
charged
chose targets with highly coveted
information because every time they
activate the tool remotely the
likelihood of detection
increases ben johnson former nsa cyber
engineer who is now
chief technology officer of software
security from obsidian said quite
honestly my heart sank when i saw some
of the details just the amount of
information they could potentially have
if they are reading everyone's emails
and they are accessing sensitive files
within places like treasury or commerce
solarwinds has customers including in
the pentagon the state department nasa
the nsa
the department of justice and the white
house so this is a full-on
disaster area and we don't know just how
deep this hack goes we have no idea what
sort of information they have access to
and again
they sort of now have a back door which
means that they can consistently be
gathering information
this is really really scary stuff
okay so according to politico the energy
department and national
nuclear security administration which
maintains the u.s nuclear weapons
stockpile have evidence that hackers
access their networks as part of an
extensive espionage operation
that has affected at least half a dozen
federal agencies they found suspicious
activity in networks belonging to the
federal energy regulatory commission
sandia and los alamos national
laboratories in new mexico and
washington the office of secure
transportation the richland field office
of the department of energy the hackers
have been able to do more damage
at the federal energy regulatory
commission than other agencies at the
official said
this is the clearest sign yet that the
hackers were able to access networks
belonging to a core part
of the us national security enterprise
so it's a full-on
disaster area and again that persistent
access means that they can basically
get in whenever they want and it's going
to be very very difficult to detect
it's also unclear exactly who is behind
it again the russians
say they are not but that cannot be
trusted so
what exactly should be done here i mean
this is basically
an active cyber war right i mean this is
cyber war senator romney
of utah he said the cyber hack is like
russian bombers have been flying
undetected over our entire country
alarming u.s vulnerability apparent
cyber warfare weakness glaring
inadequate cyber defenses inexcusable
silence
and an action from the white house
so something has to be done obviously
apparently they found more than one
doorway into u.s systems as well the
department of homeland security said
in a bulletin on thursday the spies had
used other techniques besides corrupting
updates of network management software
by solarwinds which is used by hundreds
of thousands of companies apparently
the solarwinds orion supply chain
compromise is not the only initial
infection vector this apt actor leverage
according to the dhs's cyber security
and infrastructure security
agency okay so this is obviously scary
stuff it doesn't mean by the way
that they breached any of our seriously
classified systems
but it is unclear what we know i mean
it's possible that they did
and even if they didn't the real possib
the real possibility is that there's a
lot of information that is not exactly
classified that can be leveraged against
people
right especially because the russians
love to sell confusion in the us body
politic
if they have this much access to all of
our corporate information if they have
this much access to insider government
information how much chaos can they sow
over the coming years this is really
scary stuff and the trump administration
which is still in office needs to take
harsh action
against the russians and we are talking
about
more than individual sanctions on top
russian officers i mean we have to be
talking about something much more
serious here because
this again is the largest act of cyber
espionage probably in the history of the
world
from what we can gather at this point
that does not mean that we are
moving toward open warfare with the
russians or anything like that but if we
don't take harsh action right now and
cut this off at the knees it's only
going to get worse and again
apparently a lot of these agencies
they're being told that the software is
so compromised they have to
pretty much do what hillary clinton did
to her hard drive like take this stuff
out of the wall
take it out to a field somewhere and
take a baseball bat to it like to print
or an office space
i mean that's how bad this is we'll get
some more of this in just one second
first
let us talk about the fact that now is a
bad time to go to the post office in
fact a lot of times are bad to go to the
post office but right now you don't want
to be
in crowded areas and beyond that why
would you want to schlep all of your
stuff over to the post office when you
can do everything
safely and easily from your office or
from your home here is where stamps.com
comes in this holiday season more people
will be mailing stuff than ever that
means the post office is going to be
busy you don't have time for that
stamps.com
brings the post office and now ups
shipping directly to your computer mail
and ship anything
from the convenience of your home or
office with stamps.com anything you can
do at the post office you can do with
just a few clicks
plus stamps.com saves you money with
deep discounts you can't even get at the
post office
here at dailywire we've been using
stamps.com since 2017. no more wasting
our time
stamps.com brings the services of the us
postal service and ups
directly to your computer stamps.com is
a must-have for any business
it doesn't matter if you're a small
office sending out invoices or an online
seller for filling orders during this
record setting
holiday season or even a giant warehouse
you can be using stamps.com to handle
sending all of those packages simply use
your computer to print out official us
postage 24 7 for any lego any package
any class of mail and you get five cents
off every first class stamp up to 40
off priority mail up to 62 off ups
shipping rates
so i mean this is an amazing service and
right now with my promo code shapiro you
get a special offer that includes a four
week trial plus
free postage and digital skill no
long-term commitments or contracts just
go to stamps.com
click on the microphone at the top of
the homepage type in shapiro that is
stamps.com
enter shapiro in order to get that
special deal again four week trial plus
free postage and a
digitalscalestamps.com never go
to the post office again okay so
obviously
this particular hack is incredibly scary
it demonstrates that
we have been really remiss in a lot of
our cyber security and we have not been
taking seriously the threat from foreign
countries
including russia but also including
china and the fact is that we have
talked
very little in the united states about
what ought to be done to
fight back against the chinese efforts
to develop 5g
and when we talk about using government
resources
in order to boost particular industries
it seems like the industry that needs to
be boosted the most actually is the
inter
is the industry that people in america
think needs to be boosted the least
namely the industry in the the internet
industry
the chinese are threatening the security
of the web around the world by
installation of 5g that allows them
back doors to other information and lots
of countries are taking that up if the
united states has not out developed the
chinese
in that space then pretty soon a lot of
governments a lot of companies are going
to be in hot to the chinese
that could be a full-scale disaster area
that is not something that anybody wants
at this point ron wyden oregon democrat
he says if reports are true and
state-spon
sponsored hackers successfully snuck
malware riddled software into scores of
federal government systems our country
has suffered a massive national security
failure that could have ramifications
for years to come so what exactly could
the u.s do
well theoretically we could expel
diplomats we could impose sanctions we
could file criminal charges for cyber
espionage
washington dc and the eu have done that
against russia in the past but
that has not stopped the russians so
something radical has to change and it
has to change in short order because
this stuff
is extremely extremely dangerous okay
meanwhile
the the wave of kova that is hitting the
country continues to be
extraordinarily grave the california
update is really ugly right now so
california has been locked down tight
the idea from the left and from the
press and from so many of our government
officials
is that lockdowns always work that the
best thing you can do is lock down
here's the problem california really
never stopped the lockdown and
people after a certain point they stop
obeying the lockdowns
and as it turns out if you shut down
outdoor activities that are safe
and you force people back into their
homes they're more likely to infect
members of their household as we know
from the contact racing in new york
the vast majority of people who are
obtaining covet 19 are doing so
inside their own household so here is
the story from southern california today
according to kabc
in southern california one of our
affiliates the icu capacity
in the 11 county southern california
region has now dropped to zero percent
amid a dramatic surge in coronavirus
cases officials said on thursday
california hospitals are required to
report the total number of all available
staffed icu beds each day
regional icu capacity is calculated by
subtracting it neonatal and pediatric
intensive care beds from the number of
adult beds news of the diminished icu
capacity came as the state announced the
deaths of 379 californians
marking the highest number of fatalities
in one day since the pandemic began
surpassing the previous record set the
previous day we are talking now in the
united states
about more than 3 400 deaths a day if
california we're a country right now
california itself would rank number
three
in the world in the number of diagnoses
the la county cove death toll has been
rising in la county about two people are
dying every hour on
average from the virus something the
county's public health officer called an
explosive and very deadly surge
meanwhile the vaccines are rolling out
and that is very good news
but here has been one of the big
problems with so much of what is going
on right now we require
tremendous trust in our public health
agencies and yet our public health
agencies
are very often pursuing policies that
are anti-scientific i'm talking about
the fact that public health agencies in
southern california shut down outdoor
dining
without any evidence that outdoor dining
was a chief factor of transmission
i'm talking about the fact that you have
governors and mayors all over the
country
who have shut down education even though
young people are not really chief tr
particularly children
are not chief transmission vectors of
the virus and are not dying from the
virus
the problem is that if you set
unrealistic standards it's very
difficult for people to trust the
standards that you are setting this
doesn't mean you shouldn't be taking
precautions we should be taking
precautions if we are in a situation
where icu beds are at zero
you are going to have to engage in
larger scale shutdowns of
you know things like restaurants you're
going to have to go from 50 to 25
percent
for example if that is what the science
backs the problem is people were doing
stuff that the science did not back
and then people stopped paying attention
to the scientists
one of the big questions that the
scientific establishment is going to
have to ask itself when it comes to
covet and nearly everything else
is why is it that so many people don't
believe what we are saying to them
because if we are talking
about the if we are talking about the
most one of the most valuable things
that has ever happened in human history
it's the
renewed belief in the scientific method
that began in the
enlightenment period and has developed
you know progress
and technology if you look at the
prosperity of human society life
expectancy all of this has jumped
radically because of belief
in the scientific method but one of the
problems is that over the past
50 years particularly the scientific
method has been increasingly made
secondary
to politically correct perceptions of
what the scientific method should
conclude
we now have scientists who have decided
that the conclusion is more important
than the actual method itself and people
can see that
people can see that see science is great
when science sticks to its lane
science is not great when science does
not stick to its line sciences lane is
not about the meaning of life
it is not about the meaning of the
universe and it is certainly not about
politics
science's lane was supposed to be about
trial and error scientific method
hypothesis that is falsified or not
falsified right that is what the
scientific method was
but scientism decided that science was
the solution for everything
and not only that you could merge
leftist politics with science
and people at a certain point said well
i'm not sure what to believe anymore
because you are now outside your lane
you are engaging in what we would call
ultra creptarianism you are now
operating outside your chosen field of
specialty
when the coveted sources told us for
months that anti-lockdown gatherings
were very scary but also
gatherings for george floyd were very
good because racism is a public health
problem that undermines your credibility
and the undermining of scientific
credibility is an un it's an ongoing
thing
it is happening nearly every day in
areas large and small
in american life to take a non-covid
example
the new england journal of medicine
which is probably the most prestigious
journal of medicine
in the united states put out an article
today that is so absurd and so
anti-scientific it beggars imagination
we'll get to that in just one second but
first the holidays one of the busiest
times to be on the road that means i
can't afford to deal with expensive car
repairs or my car
breaking down who has the time or money
for any of that right now certainly not
me that is why i called
car shields you should as well with car
shield you're not going to get stuck
with another high repair bill car shield
offers affordable protection that can
save you thousands of bucks for covered
repairs
whether your car has 5 000 miles or 150
000 miles on it car shield has a
protection plan for everyone
payments are flexible plans are
customizable to your exact needs you can
take your car to your favorite mechanic
or dealership to do the work
car shield will get the rest taken care
of for you even if your car breaks down
while you're traveling
the choice of a repair shop is still up
to you plus car shield gets you 24 7
nationwide roadside assistance and
if your car's going to be worked on for
a while you can get rental car coverage
too at no additional cost
car shield has helped over one million
drivers which is why they're america's
number one
auto protection company go get started
with them right now get over
being worried about car repairs because
you got the insurance to cover it with
car shield dot com drive with confidence
knowing that if anything happens you are
protected get coverage
today see why car shield cars go farther
visit car shield
dot com use code ben to save 10 again
that's car shield dot com
code bends and save 10 a deductible may
apply okay so
when i say that the scientific
establishment has really undermined its
own credibility
and this is particularly frightening at
a time
when science has been at its most
necessary i mean the fact is that
science is now going to in historic
measure
solve the covet crisis through the
creation of a vaccine
in record time it's an incredible thing
it really is
and yet the scientific community
continues to lose credibility among the
public at large
because they continue at the same time
they are pushing actual signs to push
nonsense
here's an example so the new england
journal of medicine put out an article
today
again this is a prestigious medical
journal it is titled failed assignments
rethinking sex designations on birth
certificates it is by
vadim schtayler md jessica clark jd
which is just a lawyer and ellie adashi
md
sex designations on birth certificates
offer no clinical utility
and they can be harmful for intersex and
transgender people
moving such designations below the line
of demarcation wouldn't compromise the
birth certificate's public health
function
but could avoid harm so we are now
supposed to change
we're supposed to change birth
certificates for babies because
the lie is that sex is assigned at birth
first of all the notion that sex
designations don't offer clinical
utility on birth certificates is insane
obviously they do doctors immediately
start taking care of girl babies and boy
babies a little bit differently because
they have different systems they are not
the same
they have different growth charts to
take one example the the basic idea
here from the new england journal of
medicine is that so as not to offend the
possibility
that an adult transgender person is
going to be offended
by their own birth certificate we are
now going to retroactively
remove the sex designation line on birth
certificates or move it lower on the
birth certificate
so that people who are transgender and
care about their birth certificate
meaning they're like 30
and now they're looking back at their
birth certificate and want to change
their birth certificate which by the way
not only violates the laws of biology
but also the time space continuum
because when you were born you're
actually a member of the sex to which
you are still a member
okay but now the new england journal
journal of medicine is green lighting
this kind of crap
and then people wonder why the
scientific establishment is being
undermined
i mean we had full-scale articles in
science magazines talking about how
racial justice was a public health issue
therefore it was go it was fine to go
out and protest
in the middle of a covid panzemic
another example
okay so today a university of pittsburgh
cardiologists who face backlash over an
opinion piece he wrote criticizing
affirmative action is now suing his
employers
the american heart association and the
company that published and then
retracted his article
arguing that he was demoted and defamed
because his views were unpopular
dr norman wang who is a faculty member
in pitts school of medicine
university of pittsburgh and a doctor
with university of pittsburgh physicians
was removed from his position
as director of upmc's clinical cardiac
electrophysiology fellowship program in
august
days after his article was noticed by
other cardiologists on twitter ah
twitter the greatest of all places
what's remarkable about what's
remarkable about this is that he was not
punished for an inappropriate joke
or an interpret remark in the classroom
but for publishing a thoroughly
researched article in a peer-reviewed
journal said terry pell the president of
the center for individual rights
representing wang in his suit
this should concern anybody concerned
concerned about academics and free
speech regardless of whether it
challenges
conventional thinking i mean it's pretty
amazing
the university of pittsburgh basically
demoted the guy because he wrote an
article titled diversity inclusion and
equity
evolution of race and ethnicity
considerations for the cardiology
workforce
in the united states of america from
1969 to 2019 it was published by the
journal of the american heart
association
in march the article traced the history
of the use of race and ethnicity
relative to admission into medical
school
residency programs and fellowships wang
said in the article the use of racial
preferences in bringing minorities in
medical schools can put them in
at disadvantage in the long term and
concluded it hasn't worked to diversify
the medical professional
he said none of that is controversial
it's based on data it's been written
about before
well at a july 31st meeting apparently
wang told
he was said that the school of
medicine's selection process violated
federal law this is what he said because
of the preferences used for selecting
and favoring
some applicants at that point wang was
removed from his role as director of the
clinical cardiac electrophysiology
fellowship program
so in other words he crossed the
politically woke and he and he lost
because this is the way that science is
supposed to work right now and this does
have ramifications
for things up to and including coveted
policy once you start making politically
correct decisions
and you infuse science with those
politically correct decisions
it has actual impact so here is a
perfect example okay so
right now we are deciding who the
vaccine goes to right who the coveted
vaccine
goes to first and this is a pretty
contentious issue
you've heard members of the biden team
suggest that
when we talk about health issues we
should certainly be talking first and
foremost about racial inequity
and racial inequality which they equate
right in inequity means unfairness
inequality is not unfair it's just
inequality and they say the two are
exactly the same so in other words if
more black people than white people on
average are dying of covet this
demonstrates the racial animus of the
united states which of course is
silliness
you actually have to rule out the
confounds you have to point out that
people of color and white people are not
dying at the same rates of covet
literally anywhere in the west okay but
we ignore all of that in order to reach
this conclusion
okay so when it comes to walking out the
the covid vaccine
there are a few ways we could tranche
this thing out there's only one way that
makes sense
truly there's only one way the way that
makes sense is to tranch this thing out
by health condition right i mean it's a
health condition is covet
if you have one dose of covid vaccine
and you only and you have two patients
one of whom is a young nurse of color
and the other of whom is an 85 year old
white person living in a nursing home
it's pretty obvious
to her to whom this covered vaccine
should go but here's the thing to the
woke
and to the quote-unquote scientific
community that is affected by the wilkin
is not at all obvious which is why you
saw
a member of biden's team openly saying
that when it comes to
treatments for covid we should be
looking at the treatments for kovid
through a racial lens which is wild
stuff
and does have real ramifications for
society we'll talk about those
ramifications in just one second because
this actually
is now a matter of practicality as we
roll out a limited number of vaccines
to a very large population there's not
enough vaccines to go around at the
moment we'll get to this in just one
second first
this holiday season it sure knows how to
lighten your wallet for many families
december is one of the most expensive
months of the year not to mention
the busiest if you need life insurance
but you don't want to deal with the
hassle or the expense
try policy genius policy genius combines
a cutting-edge insurance marketplace
with help from licensed experts to save
you
time and money right now you could say
50 or more by using policy genius to
compare life insurance
when you're shopping for a policy that
could last for more than a decade the
savings really do start to add up here's
how it works first
head on over to policygenius.com in
minutes you can work out how much
coverage you need
and compare quotes from top insurers to
find your best price policy genius will
compare policies starting at as little
as one dollar a day you might even be
eligible to skip that in-person medical
exam once you apply the policy genius
team will handle all the paperwork and
the red tape the best part they work for
you not the insurance company so
if you hit any speed bumps during the
application process they'll take care of
everything that kind of service has
earned policy genius a five-star rating
across over 1 600 reviews on trustpilot
and google here's the deal you're a
responsible person god forbid something
should happen to you you need the life
insurance to take care of your family
it's that simple be responsible go to
policy genius right now and get started
you could say 50
or more by comparing quotes start the
new year with one less thing to worry
about policy genius when it comes to
insurance it's nice
and quite important to get it right okay
so as i say when it comes to wokeness in
science
it has predictable effects one a lot of
people are gonna say i don't believe you
because it seems like your political
priorities are now taking precedence
over your scientific priorities
and in many areas of american life this
is obviously true when you are talking
about an entire medical establishment
that is bought into gender ideology
nonsense that has nothing to do with
science
i understand why people have lost faith
when you have a bunch of scientists who
declare not just that climate change is
happening
and not just that human activity
contributes largely to climate change
but that the solution
to that is invariably to crush the
american economy
that is now politics that is no longer
science right you have moved out of the
realm in which you are experts into a
realm in which you are not experts
but when it comes to covid more than
anything else it has
real ramifications because now we're
talking about life and death issues so
go back to
december 6th if you go back to december
6th there's an article
in the new york times titled the elderly
versus essential workers
who should get the coronavirus vaccine
first the cdc will soon decide which
group to recommend next the debate over
trade-offs is growing
heated ultimately states will determine
who to include
okay so what is the debate here it's
pretty obvious that the answer here
should be the elderly right
i mean if you are an essential worker
and you are 40 years old and you are
healthy
your chances of dying from this thing
are literally
in many cases 100 times lower than your
chances of dying of this thing
if you happen to be 85 and you have a
pre-existing condition i mean we're
talking about
a death rate of like .05 i think it's
point five percent
for people who are you know below the
age of
65 and once you are over the age of 75
the death rates on this thing rise to
like four or five percent you're talking
about
a a in some cases
somewhere between a 10 and a 100 full
difference in
exactly how deadly this thing is right
so i mean that's a pretty significant
difference is it not
okay you're talking about the difference
between five deaths in a thousand versus
five deaths in a hundred
and yet we are now being told that this
should be an open debate
okay so the new york times covered it
this way this is pretty amazing
harold schmidt an expert in ethics and
health policy at the university of
pennsylvania
said it is reasonable to put essential
workers ahead of older adults given
their risks and that they are
disproportionately minorities
okay ready for this line there's an
amazing line remember
he's an expert in ethics and health
policy nothing says ethics quite like
you should die based on the color of
your skin here's what dr schmidt says
older populations are whiter society is
structured in a way that enables them to
live longer
instead of giving additional health
benefits to those who have already had
more of them
we can start to level the playing field
a bit
okay i need to examine that a little
more slowly what he's actually saying is
that
elderly people people who are 85 in
nursing homes are disproportionately
white
so even though they are also at
radically disproportionate risk of dying
of coca-19
we should allow them to die so that a
person of color who's an essential
worker
and has a tenfold or a hundred fold
lower risk of death right a 20 year old
who is working in an essential industry
should get that vaccine because they're
black while an 85 year old woman who
happens to be white
should die in a nursing home because
after all society is structured that
there are more 85 year old white people
in nursing homes than 85 year old black
people in nursing homes proportionately
speaking
you know how insane that is you know how
wild that is
to protect older people more at risk dr
schmidt called on the cdc committee to
also
integrate the agency's own social
vulnerability index
the index includes 15 measures derived
from the census such as overcrowded
housing
lack of vehicle access and poverty to
determine how urgently a community
needs health support with the goal of
reducing inequities
not the goal of reducing overall death
mind you the goal of reducing inequities
now the first rule when it comes to
medicine is do no harm you are obviously
doing harm if you are tranching out
the vaccine to people who are less
vulnerable rather than to people who are
more vulnerable
because you are basically saying more
white people should die because white
people are historically advantaged in
the united states
i mean this is this is wild stuff
to suggest that we are we are to rate
as more important factors racial
constituency or socio-economic status
rather than your risk factor of dying of
covid is a demonstration that science
takes a backseat to politics it just
does
it's a good article about this by a
doctor named buzz hollander over at real
clear science
today talking about the
the attempts to tranche this thing out
right now the the strategy is to roll
this thing out
to people in nursing homes but also to
roll it out to
people who are essential workers in
medicine
but as he says here's the problem if
you're talking about essential workers
in medicine
they're not among the people most likely
to die if you have to decide between
giving it to
my wife who is a 33 year old family
medicine doctor
and giving it to an 85 year old woman in
nursing home we should absolutely give
it to the 85 year old woman in the
nursing home
no question okay this is what dr
hollander says he says here is my
greatest beef with the current plan as
endorsed by the cdc
we might only have 19 million doses in
our first round i will not quibble with
allocating two million to care for home
to home to care home residents as they
have been responsible for roughly 40
of deaths in the united states i also
want to argue with administering to
roughly another 2 million staff for
those homes
because we can't be sure that nursing
home residents will mount an effective
immune response to the vaccines
you have to protect the people around
the members of the nursing home however
giving the next 15 million doses to
health care workers does not compute by
any calculus valuing lives saved
i know the arguments they put themselves
at risk they are needed healthy
for hospitals to function smoothly they
tend to roll up their sleeves and more
more willingly than average americans
the problem is they don't die very often
right this is the the math doesn't work
out approximately 0.5 percent of u.s
deaths from covet have been healthcare
workers approximately 80 percent
of u.s deaths from covenant 19 have been
from those over the age
of 65. 80 versus 0.5 how is this even a
question
there there are a bunch of doctors
who've been writing this recently
he says this is just simple ethics is it
really right for me as a 51 year old
healthy immensely privileged white guy
to be given a vaccine in two weeks while
my 87 year old father living our
multi-generational household might wait
another two to three months
know first do no harm but what about
first do not steal
here's the pragmatics if we agree my
father is on the order of 160 times more
likely to die of covet 19 than me
does it make sense to give me the
vaccine first but the answer for a lot
of folks
is yes because wokeness takes precedence
hey here are some other things that we
are not doing that we should be doing
because we have decided that we are not
going to tell people that once you have
actually had this thing you are
basically immune
which most science suggests you are the
chance of reinfection are exorbitantly
low
then one of the things that we are not
doing that we absolutely should be doing
is we should be antibody testing people
before we give them the vaccine correct
i mean this is a pretty easy answer you
should be antibody testing people make
sure they're not already immune before
you give them a dose of the vaccine
remember
this is a limited number of vaccine
doses why would you dose somebody with a
vaccine who's already immune
to the to the virus like
the fact that that everybody seems to
not want to talk about antibody tests
it's kind of insane
as dr hollander says best estimates
would hold that the 16 million
identified cases of covenant 19 in the
u.s
probably amount to more like 60 million
or even 100 million actual cases let's
say there are 80 million total cases
of the 64 million without a history of
pcr-positive tests
if we estimate a rapid antibody test to
spike proteins correctly identifies 80
of these we have 51 million more
americans with probable immunity
so you can exclude 20 percent of people
from the first waves of vaccination
with very low life-saving cost also why
aren't we transferring the vaccines to
places where people are most likely to
die
right we should be out we should be
sending more vaccine right now for
example to la county than to san
francisco because san francisco is not
getting
hit as hard also we should be
rolling this stuff out as fast as
humanly possible
so according to this doctor he says
trying to keep the vaccines in storage
for three to four weeks to maintain
perfect allocation for a booster shot as
to the challenge
it cuts in half the number of vaccine
doses available right now the us
government recommends this practice
perhaps to avoid any appearance of
legitimizing a one-dose regimen but we
should be on appearances
at this point former fta head scott
gottlieb is not a fan of holding back
doses he says i don't think we should be
holding onto supply right now
anticipating something goes wrong that's
going to cause a lot of other challenges
we should be taking some risk
what he means is right now for every
dose that we are putting out there
there's another dose that we're holding
back for a month basically
so we can give it to in a month but we
know that more doses are going to come
online in a month so why not tranch
the early immunity out as fast as
humanly possible
right let's let's trust that people are
going to actually produce where they're
supposed to re
produce okay so so moving forward these
are
like this these are all practical things
but they've all become politicized
they've all become politicized
and the fact that they've become
politicized is a disaster for the united
states and it's
a disaster for the scientific
institutions of the country
the fact that that our political leaders
are being treated as celebrities
and our scientific leaders are being
treated as celebrities and none of them
seem to be able to hold a consistent
standard
with regard to science is pretty
astonishing remember never forget the
same media
that has decided that they know best
about covet has also decided that andrew
cuomo is the greatest of all governors
by the way speaking of governor andrew
cuomo
some late breaking news from andrew
cuomo if you're a restaurant owner
should be overjoyed that he shut down
your restaurant here was governor cuomo
from new york yesterday
i have all sorts of people who are
concerned well you went down
to 25 indoor dining you cancelled indoor
dining
you're requesting more testing for
people in salons
lower capacity in gyms yes
to all of that that is not the real
problem we're trying to change the
trajectory
well i'm upset that you're trying to
change the trajectory you should be
happy
because if we don't change the
trajectory we're going to go to shut
down and then your business is going to
close
and that my friends is a real problem
well no actually a real problem has been
that you have not followed the data
pretty much anywhere here along the way
andrew cuomo
i mean you shut down the schools when
they didn't need to be shut down you
were shutting down the restaurants when
they didn't need to be shut down or at
least putting on
putting in place restrictions that were
not sensical you're going out there and
leaving the nursing homes wide open to
covet
and yet this is the guy that the media
have been trotting out there systemic
distrust is a real problem
it really is and just because somebody
has an md by their name
or they have a or they have a phd by
their name or just because they're an
elected official does not mean that what
they are saying
is logical okay what's logical is
logical and what is scientific and
scientific and what is not is not it is
that simple and i think the american
people have enough common sense
to know that or at least i hope they do
i think one of the big problems here is
that
people tend to throw the baby out with
the bath water they look at the fact
that they've been lied to by public
officials and that health officials
can't seem to get their act together on
a regular basis or that they infuse
science with politics
and then they say okay well i'm just
throwing out the whole thing and that is
probably the worst problem
of all when you undermine the
credibility of your own institution
people just don't take your institution
seriously
when you're talking about an institution
as serious as the scientific
establishment of the united states that
is a serious serious issue
alrighty coming up we're going to get
into joe biden who
continues to maintain that hunter biden
is the is the
cap of all innocence he's just he's he's
the most innocent per he's also the most
brilliant person joe biden knows which
is
not that's pretty damning indictment of
his friendship circle in any case we'll
get to
more in one second first let us talk
about the fact that you need to protect
yourself against malware and ransomware
um like did you hear that part where i
said that the russians have hacked like
every single institution in the united
states and around the globe
and they did so with malware and with
ransomware well you need
to do what the government apparently did
not and protect yourself
pcmatic it's a next-generation
anti-virus designed to stop threats like
ransomware
independent testing from a v test just
named at pcmatica top performer in the
cyber security industry
giving it the best performance award for
2019 only pcmatic has american research
development and support pcmatic's
competition is foreign made often in
countries where malware originates
pcmatic will block annoying and
malicious ads for hassle-free web
browsing and makes your computer faster
and more reliable
even after years of use pcmatic protects
windows computers including xp
vista windows 7 8 and 10 windows servers
macs macbooks and android phones and
tablets
pcmatic is just 50 bucks for five
devices for one year full 30 day money
back guarantee if you act right now
pcmatic has offered my listeners a free
month of security protection with the
purchase
of an annual license so right now head
on over to pcmatic.com to access this
magical offer again
get world-class security that keeps your
computer running great go to pcmatic.com
ben all right we're gonna get to more of
the news in just one moment first
on monday december 21st which is coming
up real fast right here i mean we were
talking about this monday the historical
docu series apollo 11 what we saw will
be available exclusively at
dailywire.com
originally released as an audio podcast
for apple and spotify what we saw
will be available to watch as well as
listen to on the daily wire apple tv or
roku app or at dailywire.com
the docuseries takes a detailed look at
the apollo 11 mission to land a man on
the moon perhaps one of the greatest
achievements in the history of mankind
and was the culmination
of the cold war and our cold war rivalry
it's a dramatically inspiring story
you're gonna love it it really is it's
an awesome awesome piece of work it is
beautiful to watch
go check it out right now apollo 11 what
we saw great to watch with loved ones
make you patriotic over the holiday
break right now get it for 20
off with code watch when you become an
insider or above member over at
dailywire.com
subscribe and make sure to
subscribe to get downl off your
membership with codewatch and access to
all of our new
and existing content also by the way
make sure to tune in to daily wires
backstage that is happening this monday
the 21st
8pm eastern 5 pm pacific for a special
december christmas episode we will all
be together again socially distance of
forced but we'll be sharing
the christmas spirit with you i know
some weird things are going to happen
during that show
maybe you will enjoy them more than i
did but i i think
we'll enjoy them together how about that
head on over to dailywire.com and use
promo code watch for 20
off your subscription today you are
listening to the largest fastest growing
conservative podcast and radio show in
the nation
[Music]
so quick further note on covet the
stimulus talks that should have been
held months ago
are still going on apparently this is
going to drag into the weekend according
to the washington post white house
officials and congressional leaders
are trying to address a number of
lingering policy disagreements as they
race to finalize
an approximately 900 billion coronavirus
relief package with growing signs the
talks will drag into the weekend
negotiators were hoping to resolve all
of their differences and pass matching
bills in the house and senate by friday
night
that appeared to slip away late on
thursday lawmakers first have to pass a
stopgap spending deal by
spending bill by friday night to avoid a
government shutdown on saturday then
they will continue to negotiate
through the weekend it turns out that
the best negotiator in the building
once again is senator mitch mcconnell
who has basically
traded no state and local aid uh in
favor of no liability he says we'll hold
all that stuff
out for a future bill so all the talk
about how he was being forced into
concessions by the democrats
turns out not really so true this has of
course
ticked off the members of the
progressive caucus and democrats in the
senate are like guys we still have to
make a deal here mark warner
chided bernie sanders no han omar
because i'm not sure why we're going to
them for advice on how to cut a covet
deal they've never cut a deal in their
entire lives
these are folks who've never negotiated
any deal
that i think has ever been successful i
mean we're dealing with a
senate that is still unfortunately
controlled by the republicans we still
have donald trump
uh as president and controlling
two-thirds
in a sense of the federal government the
executive in the senate and
the alternative would have been to have
people
get kicked off of unemployment get
kicked out of their apartments
not get the kind of food assistance
that's needed okay so he happens to be
right but the fact is that
the radicals in the democratic party
base will continue to push for more and
more and more and more by the way some
of the things the democrats wanted here
was basically unlimited authority
for the federal government to lend to
anybody as long as they declare an
emergency it's pretty incredible
stuff okay meanwhile joe biden continues
to uh
run around suggesting that his son
hunter is being victimized in some way
uh he was on stephen colbert's show the
fact that the hard-hitting questions
come from stephen colbert
demonstrates that your media is
absolutely 100 corrupt
cbs evening news with nora o'donnell
quoted the late show with stephen
colbert to interview biden
that's how insane this is right norah
o'donnell didn't actually do an
interview with joe biden and ask him
serious questions about hunter
no joe biden very serious guy right
super saiyan
we've you know now we're beyond the age
of entertainment politics
you remember those bad old days of trump
with the entertainment politics
no he we never had an entertainment
president before except for barack obama
who did interviews with glozella and
pimp with limp
but now we have joe biden very serious
serious like super serious guy so
serious that he won't do sit down
interviews with anybody who's actually
serious
but he will sit down with faux comic
stephen colbert
to basically do propaganda so stephen
colbert said you know
mr mr president-elect you know let me
just ask you you know is
people are being so mean to hunter
they're being so mean to hunter like are
you upset that they're being so mean to
hunter and here's your bite saying yes
indeed i'm
dead we have great confidence in our son
i'm not concerned about any accusations
but made against him
it's used to get to me i think it's kind
of
foul play but look it is what it is and
he's a grown man he is the smartest man
i know
i mean afraid of pure intellectual
capacity
um and uh and as long as he's good
we're good the smartest man he knows
well i might need to know some more
smart people because um
hunter biden is a dum-dum sorry
running around to foreign countries and
uh and picking up bags of cash because
your last name is biden does not make
you smart
other things that don't make you smart
would include apparently dropping off
your broken laptop with pictures of you
doing drugs with like
hookers on a computer in delaware and
just leaving it there
those are things that do not actually
make you smart
when joe biden suggests that hunter
biden is smart and not only that
that it's a corrupt it's foul play it's
foul play it's out to get him question
why is it foul play apparently this
investigation's been ongoing since 2019.
so where exactly is the foul play right
here the answer is there is no foul play
this is one of the reasons
why the attorney general who is still
william barr until next week
should appoint a special counsel in the
hunter biden investigation because is
there
there's very little doubt that joe biden
would come and immediately quash that
thing right
joe biden would probably come in he
would kill that investigation dead and
then the media would just cheer
because after all the media didn't even
want to cover this stuff before the
election
meanwhile with regard to sort of
breaking news here
hunter biden's former business partners
apparently
said explicitly they wanted to get joe
involved without joe knowing
this hot air fox news published a story
today highlighting some text messages
between hunter biden's former business
associates
james gillier and tony babilinski the
messages from 2017 involve a plan to set
up a business deal with the chinese
energy company
the pair were eager to get joe biden
involved but also warned about
mentioning he would be involved except
in face-to-face communications in april
of 2017 bob linski asked gillier
why jim biden was part of the discussion
when they already had hunter on board
gillier said with h's demons could be
good to have a backup he strengthens our
usp
to chinese as it looks like a truly
family business and i like the dude
apparently that would be the unique
selling proposition whatever the case
the point is clearly that having two
bidens involved adds to the suggestion
the entire family
is involved in early may the same two
were discussing a meeting with the
chairman of the chinese company and the
need for an a-lister to be at the
meeting
gillier then texted bobolinski with the
hope that joe may come sunday he added
i'm hoping
bobalinski called that a no-brainer
biden apparently didn't attend that
meeting
on may 11th balinsky texted gillier
again saying
man you are right let's get the company
set up let's tell h
and the family the high stakes and get
joe involved
okay but don't worry everything is pure
as the driven snow everything is
absolutely wonderful and hunter is the
smartest person everybody knows except
for how his business partners are like
god
we can't go to the chinese with this
tool bag we gotta have something better
than this
have a like jim let's get jim maybe
we'll get joe
like somebody who's not hunter goodness
gracious
don't worry guys this is this biden
administration is going to be pure as
the drive
his only scandal presumably will also be
some odd colored suit
obama's only scandal is his hand suit
he's going to work a maw of suit or
something
and that'll be his big scandal he'll
look like joe pesci and my cousin vinnie
one day at press conference and that'll
be his big scandal
that'll just be mainly because he
doesn't know what to dress in because
somebody else has to dress him every day
in any case the the election 2020 doubts
continue
a pace uh people have been trotting out
a couple of pieces of video
they're both trending on twitter
overnight and i think it is worthy of
pointing out that these pieces of video
are um are really
not particularly convincing one is one a
a
video of arizona state senator eddie
farnsworth this was going viral last
night
suggesting that in the texas case the
supreme court justices went into a room
and started yelling at each other about
why they should not go along with the
texas case
uh here is this clip this clip had
millions of views over over the last 24
hours
there's only one pretty large problem
with it here was this arizona state
senator
when the texas case was brought up he
said he heard
screaming through the walls
as justice roberts and the other liberal
justices
were insisting that this case not be
taken
up and the reason the words that were
heard through the wall
when justice thomas and justice lolito
were citing bush versus score
from john roberts where i don't give up
about that case i don't want to hear
about it
at that time we didn't have riots
okay um i have a question the supreme
court justice
they're not meeting in person so
obviously that that is not true other
things that are not true
apparently lynn wood is now tweeting out
that john roberts called trump an
mfer lynn wood tweeted out in discussing
trump in phone conversation
on 819 justice john so august 19th
justice john roberts stated he would
make sure
the mfr would never be re-elected
roberts engaged in phone conversation
with justice stephen breyer discussing
how to work to get trump voted out like
i don't know where linwood is getting
any of this crap
there's no evidence that this is the
case at all bottom line is that
if all this does is just to undermine
people's willingness to vote in the
georgia senate races it is a
huge error it's a huge error okay this
is not just me saying this is mike pence
who by the way good for mike pence he
was
vaccinated this morning you do want the
top levels of government presumably
vaccinated and uh how old is mike pence
he's
about 60 probably mike pence says um
he was vaccinated this morning they were
saving doing it um but on the georgia
stuff he said if you don't vote they win
now i know we've all got doubts about
the last election
and that's why we're going to keep right
on fight
but i got to tell you you know i hear
some people saying
down here in georgia if you're
frustrated about the last election just
don't vote
[Music]
[Applause]
my fellow americans i say for my heart
you got to remember if you don't vote
they win
okay that is exactly right you know who
else knows that by the way joe biden
right joe biden came out he says
moderate joe he says i need raphael
warnock and john ossoff i need them
give them to me don't give them to him
guys
my administration is preparing to beat
coven 19 and get economic relief to the
american people
on day one as your president i'm
prepared to sign a covert relief package
that fully funds the public health
response needed led by georgia's own cdc
it will ensure free testing and
vaccination for
every american and will get small
businesses
the assistance they need right now let
me be clear
i need rafael warnock and john ossoff in
the united states senate
to get this done no you you really don't
like a lot of those things are going to
happen anyway
and also there is no one who is too
radical for joe biden to endorse
apparently
uh also kudos to the guy who's playing
the soft synthesizer music in the
background
uh that that really is it's like from a
yoga retreat in the background because
if if biden wasn't putting him putting
you to sleep right there
on his own they had to have synthesizer
guy in the background playing the soft
music as the waterfalls tinkle in the
background
okay meanwhile the the
same democratic party that suggests that
it's time for unity the media that
suggests
the election is over it's time for unity
let's all get together and have happy
times together
meanwhile the democrats just keep saying
awful things about republicans because
this is the way that it works guys
don't you understand it's time for unity
by which they mean surrender
it's time for you and they don't just
mean surrender in the election 2020.
right the the
electoral college is already voted they
mean surrender forever right surrender
your priorities
just let the democrats have their way
with the country that is what they mean
right so barack obama captain unity
right he's doing his book tour
he's he's such a unifying figure
remember according to the media this guy
was
the most unifying figure in modern
american politics he really just brought
people together that's all barack obama
did he was unbelievably divisive
and the rise of the intersectional
coalition the rise of intersectionality
is a philosophy
it really occurred under his watch and
it was a political move by obama
that he really started to treat separate
segments of the american population as
voting blocks that he could appeal to
and then cobble together a coalition
against the quote unquote system
that really did break apart i think that
if the country
is is irrevocably broken a lot of people
on the left are going to attribute that
to election 2016. uh no way
no way the country got broken in 2012.
that's when the country got broken
in 2008 barack obama ran as a
traditional unifying
political figure right no red states no
blue states the united states by 2012
he had basically decided that he was
going to abandon pushing a message that
was
acceptable and palatable and interesting
for a majority of americans he was
instead going to go to each
intersectional group
tell them he's going to prioritize their
needs cobble them together and then
direct them at the overarching system
and suggest that if you disagree with
him it was because you're bigoted
against those specific groups
if somebody broke american politics it
was this schmuck anyway here's the
schmuck
saying that the gop is the minority
party and then saying that the senate
basically shouldn't exist anymore so
that's exciting
he attacks the senate and the electoral
college but
don't worry unity is on its way guys the
era of good feelings is here
the republican party is the minority
party in this country
the only reason that it doesn't look
like they're the minority party is
because of
structures like the u.s senate uh
and the electoral college that don't
render them the majority party
so so they have certain built-in
advantages
around power given their population
distribution and how
uh our government works but the truth of
the matter is is that 60
of the people are are occupying what i
would consider
a more reality based uh
universe okay by the way isn't this
hilarious stuff
he's saying that to trevor noah on
comedy central i mean that's comedying
right there and trevor noah just sitting
there
like so here is your very serious
democratic party joe biden being
interviewed by stephen colbert
and barack obama being interviewed by
trevor noah slow clap for the
anti-entertainment crew
the very serious political crew how did
they get trump i can't imagine i can by
the way he happens to be wrong about
this when he says that the democrats are
the majority party
he is right on a federal level right now
in terms of the house
and in terms of the presidential vote he
is certainly wrong on the state level
on the state level right now
the the state level chambers republicans
control
about 3 900 seats in state legislative
houses
and the democrats control about 3 400
seats in state legislative houses
okay when it comes to state senate
republicans control 32 state senates
democrats control 18. okay so
no that is not correct okay it turns out
we do have a series
the reason he hates the senate of course
is because he dislikes the fact that
there are institutional obstacles to
cramming down
his pure mob rule majoritarian ideas on
everybody else
that's really what he wants to do and
then people wonder why why republicans
and conservatives feel threatened
we understand that you guys want to get
rid of all the militating institutions
that preserve individual rights
we get it we understand that you just
want a bare majority to force
itself on the bare minority that you
don't want any of those rights protected
so long as the
as long as the communal interests cut
the other way
and and it's not just obama obviously
it's people like
this biden inaugural official so there's
a biden inaugural official named
stephanie cutter right she was also
a a member of the team hillary
and a member of the obama team as well
and so stephanie cutter
tweeted out in the wake of the
statement by jen o'malley dylan who is
one of biden's deputy chiefs of staff
she suggested that republicans were
efforts right so now stephanie cutter
who was a longtime senior advisor to
barack obama said quote this story is
based on one anonymous donor really
and does anyone really disagree with the
sentiment this is because axios ran a
piece
saying that some biden aides were
worried that o'malley dylan had called
the gop efforts
so stephanie cutter said the story is
based on one anonymous donor really does
anyone really disagree with the
sentiment
jen just had the guts to say it will
republicans prove it wrong doubt it
okay well so in other words she's right
right so you have top obama official and
a top
biden official both saying that
republicans are efforts but don't worry
guys it's time for unity it's time to
get together why won't republicans just
give it up why won't republicans just
you know sit down and shut up
meanwhile you have msnbc host maddie
hassan suggesting that donald trump
should be overtly prosecuted for covet
deaths
yes the era of good feelings is here
guys there will be no recriminations
it's not going to be about
punishing the other side it's not it's
not about viciousness or cruelty
it is simply about you know bringing
back a time of unity and
togetherness that's that's why we're now
calling for the prosecution of the
sitting president of the united states
for the effects of a global pandemic
that have killed millions of people all
over the planet donald trump killed
hundreds of thousands of people who
presided over the deaths
of hundreds of thousands of people
preventable death here at home
in the united states of america and that
for me you know you talk about morally
abominable it's sociopathic
and i think people should be held to
account i think they should be
prosecuted the people behind these
preventable deaths
should be prosecuted when they leave
office on january 20th
so this is this is where things stand in
our culture right now is that people
must be punished people must be punished
charles blow has another terrible column
in the new york times i mean it's
another week so of course he has another
terrible terrible column
saying just the same thing right he says
joe biden
as he has always said is seeking to be a
unifying president to be the president
of the people who didn't vote for him
as well as the ones who did i want to
have that same optimistic spirit but i i
admit my attempts at it may falter
i don't want to be the person who holds
a grudge but i also don't want to be the
person who ignores a lesson
the act of remembering that so many
americans were willing to continue the
harm to me and others into the country
itself
isn't spiteful but wise so in other
words
remember that so many people voted for
trump they are the enemy
they are the enemy anybody who voted for
trump is the enemy
meanwhile you got kareem abdul-jabbar
openly suggesting
that we have to go after hollywood stars
who do not go along with the prevailing
of political norms
right here's how it feels to be for
those who are not conservative listen to
the show understand how it feels to be a
conservative in america
okay and facts don't care about your
feelings but the facts happen to back up
these particular feelings
okay there is a tsunami of institutional
hatred
against people who think differently
than the left the left is in control of
the scientific establishment the left is
in control of the university
establishment they're in control of the
media establishment they're in control
of the entertainment establishment
they're in control of the sports
establishment they're in control
of the of the government establishment
as well particularly in the
in the administrative state it feels as
though everywhere you turn there are
people who are sneering at you
now there are people on the hardcore
left say good that's the way it should
be but
if you are a good-hearted liberal and
you wish to have open conversations with
people
what you're gonna have to decide is
whether you wish to make common clause
with the sneerers
or whether you wish to make common
clause with people who still believe in
individual rights because here's the
thing there's a high correlation between
the people who sneer
at people who think differently and the
people who wish to shut those people
down
and violate individual rights in the
process
now kareem abdul-jabbar has a piece in
the hollywood report i mean it's a
perfect confluence of celebrity
saying that celebrities deserve a legacy
killing backlash
when they spread ignorance he says the
only thing people enjoy more than
watching a celebrities rocketing a sense
of international fame
is watching and aging celebrities
flaming plummet to the hard-cold ground
of disgrace and obscurity
it is both a warning against hubris
believing you're too famous to fall and
a reminder that the same people who made
you popular
can turn on you some like bill cosby and
harvey weinstein committed heinous acts
to obliterate their achievements
but social media has provided a weapon
for others to commit instantaneous
career suicide and destroy any good
faith legacy they spent a lifetime
building
like howard hughes whose contributions
to aviation and filmmaking were
overshadowed by such
eccentricities as collecting his own
nail clippings in jars
these figures are obscuring their own
careers
so he talks about rudy giuliani and then
he talks about jk rowling
right jk rowling is super bad terrible
terrible terrible because jk rowling
says that boys and girls exist
says kareem abdul-jabbar she deserves
the hatred he says her anti-trans tweets
may not only damage the harry potter and
fantastic beasts franchises they could
have changing her entire
literary legacy even the stars of the
movies
daniel radcliffe emma watson rubert
grint eddie redmayne have spoken out
against her position well you know
if eddie redmayne says the thing well
then
hold the fort john cleese's tone deaf
defensive rallying left many fans
bitterly disappointed tarnishing his
reputation
and then he goes after jon voight and
then he goes after roseanne barr
he goes after basically anybody who
disagrees with him he says many imbue
many americans imbue stars with
political and social intelligence they
just don't have
great success in one field can lead to
the delusion that all your thoughts are
great
says the former basketball center who is
now writing in the hollywood reporter
about politics yes yes it can can't it
it does it's true there are a lot of
people who think that because they're
famous they know things and then
interesting
kareem abdul-jabbar the irresponsibility
of tweeting irrational and harmful
opinions to millions regardless of the
damaging consequences to their country
or people's lives proves these stars
deserve the harsh backlash again we are
back in the mode of
all that matters here is the is the
effect that it has on leftist feelings
that's all that matters
and the there will be a backlash to all
this there will and it's going to be
ugly when it comes
okay so we've reached the end of the
week i'm going to give you a a quick
biblical note before we hit the weekend
because i like to end the week
on a bit of uplift so this week the jews
read the torah portion
that has to do with joseph joseph is now
down in egypt
he has become the vizier to the to the
pharaoh and uh he his brothers
who put him in a pit and thought he was
going to die right they saw they sold
him to a caravan of roaming nomads
his brothers arrived down in egypt and
they have no idea who he is and so we
get this whole interplay between joseph
and his brothers in which finally at the
in next week in
the bible uh joseph reveals himself to
his brothers he reveals himself to his
father he's been long as strange from
all of them it's very moving
but there there's something else in in
this week's torah portion
in the in this week's portion of the
bible that i find really interesting
there's some real socio-economic stuff
uh in this week's torah portion so after
joseph becomes the chief advisor to
pharaoh
or right before he makes this
proposition to pharaoh so pharaoh has a
dream
pharaoh's dream is essentially as
interpreted by joseph that there are
going to be
seven fat years and then sunny and then
seven skinny years they're gonna be
seven years
of real productivity and then they're
gonna be seven years of famine
and then joseph goes beyond the analysis
of pharaoh's dream
he says let pharaoh seek out an
understanding and wise man and appoint
him over the land of egypt
let pharaoh do this and appoint
officials over the land and prepare the
land of egypt during the seven years of
plenty
let them collect all the food of those
coming good years and let them gather
the grain under pharaoh's hand
food in the cities and keep it thus the
food will remain as
a reserve for the land for the seven
years of famine which will be in the
land of egypt so the land will not be
destroyed by the famine
okay so pharaoh says good idea so what
we're gonna do is it's it's you know
gonna be a time of prosperity as
prophesied
and so what we're going to do is we're
going to centralize all the grain
okay and we're going to do this to
protect the citizenry okay the next
thing
that happens is that pharaoh appoints
joseph over the entire land of egypt
pharaoh gives his ring to joseph he puts
on him a raymond to find lemon linen he
puts a golden chain around his neck
he has him ride the chariot and then
pharaoh says to joseph i am pharaoh
besides you no one may lift his hand or
foot in the entire land
of egypt joseph gets married joseph has
a couple of kids and here is what
happens in the seven years of plenty
the inhabitants of the land gathered
food by handfuls and he collected all
the food of the seven years that was in
the land of egypt he placed the food in
the cities the food of the fields
surrounding the city
he put within it joseph gathered grain
like the sea of the sand in great
abundance until one stopped counting
because there was no number
okay and here is what happens next
because here's where things get a little
dicey the seven years of famine began as
joseph had said there was famine in all
the lands but throughout the land of
egypt there was bread
when the entire land of egypt hungered
the people cried out to pharaoh for
bread but pharaoh said to all the
egyptians go to joseph what he tells you
do
now the famine spread out all over the
face of the land joseph opened all the
storehouses in which there was grain
he sold it to the egyptians and the
famine intensified in the land of egypt
all of the inhabitants of the land came
to egypt to joseph to purpose for the
famine
had been had intensified in the entire
land
okay because what actually happened is
that when people came to joseph and said
give us the grain instead what joseph
did
is he said you're going to have to sell
me your land okay we're taking control
over all of the land
and we're gonna give you back the grain
in other words when you centralize power
in a centralized command very often that
centralized command that is going to
give you benefits right it's gonna it's
gonna help you later on
there's always a cost to that and the
cost of that is often very grave
now the great irony of this is that
after having reduced the entire egyptian
population to essentially vassalry
because the crown has now the the
pharaoh has now taken complete ownership
according to the bible
of all of the land after all of that
happens
you now have a subject population
subject to the whims of pharaoh they're
essentially he's essentially their
feudal lord
and their next move is well you know the
jews are coming in the jews are given
sort of a choice
spot by joseph right joseph gives his
family a choice spot over in the land of
goshen
and pharaoh says well a new pharaoh
arises
in the next book of the bible and he
says they're becoming kind of powerful
over there what if we just enslave them
and the rest of the population of egypt
goes yeah that sounds good
because it seems like this joseph
character you know the one we all sold
our land to
seems like his family is doing okay what
if we just make them slaves they're
becoming too powerful
so in other words there are actual costs
once you
once you reduce the population to the
vassal right once you remove the
independent spirit
once you tell them they can't own the
land they are dependent on the
government
it is much easier for them to think of
not only dispensing with their own
freedoms but the freedoms of others
i don't think the bible is being i don't
think that the bible is being
complimentary of joseph's strategy here
i think that the bible
is pointing out that joseph in becoming
sort of the chief agent of pharaoh's
seizing centralized power is paving the
way for that centralized power to be
used exactly against joseph's family
that should be a lesson
to everybody who calls for a grand
centralization of power such that it can
be used for your own benefit
because sooner rather than later it
probably will not be used to your
benefit it will be used to your
detriment
okay we'll be back here next week with
much much more also later today we'll be
here for two additional hours of content
while you wait head on over to
michaelmole's show right now he is also
talking about the kareem abdul-jabbar
story attacking conservatives and
anti-woke celebrities
in the meantime if we don't see you have
a wonderful weekend i'm ben shapiro this
is the ben shapiro show
[Music]
the ben shapiro show is produced by
colton haas executive producer jeremy
boring
our supervising producers are mathis
glover and robert sterling
production manager pavel wydowsky our
associate producers are rebecca doyle
and savannah dominguez
the show is edited by adam sci events
audio is mixed by mike coromina
hair and makeup is by fabiola christina
production assistant jessica crams
the ben shapiro show is a daily wire
production copyright 2020.
you know the matt wall show it's not
just another show about about politics i
think there are enough of those
already out there we talk about culture
because culture drives
politics and it drives everything else
so my main focuses
are life family faith
those are fundamental and that's what
this show is about i hope you'll
give it a listen